okay so i had watched about 30 seconds
of the
interview section of this video
and was like oh no
this needs to be recorded
so we're about to watch the um
facebook do we even get to call it
facebook anymore the conference from
mark zuckerberg where he announced meta
and spoke about gaming in the metaverse
i almost feel like i should make this a
try not to cringe video because what i
watched of the interview i was like
oh god but i do want to preface this by
saying that i am genuinely interested in
this content i am genuinely interested
in kind of any evolution of gaming um
i'm a huge fan of the oculus quest too
even if i don't use facebook and don't
love that it requires you to have one
sorry
meta it's never gonna catch on i'm sorry
mark but yeah i'm i'm a very big fan of
vr and of ar
um so i'm i'm genuinely interested in
this tech i'm not in the habit of like
just memeing on
new tech because like people don't like
the thing like i didn't do it with
stadia i'm not gonna do it with this i'm
not gonna tell you that i don't like any
part of gaming in the metaverse um just
because it's very popular
not to like mark zuckerberg and facebook
because i do care
about video games i do care about
advancements in the tech
i got into game development for a reason
i also that said
i'm a person who has trouble making fun
of people
if i'm friends with them they get
roasted all day every day
but generally speaking i don't like
laughing at people i don't like making
fun of mark zuckerberg for being awkward
but
holy [ __ ] so i haven't watched this
whole video i believe the start is more
of a presentation and then there's the
interview which is what i saw that just
oh my god tough to get through let's go
gaming in the metaverse is going to span
from immersive experiences in fantasy
worlds to bringing simple games into our
everyday life what was that
span from immersive experiences oh
there's reflection in the shot what a
weird choice
through holograms maybe you'll play old
games in new ways
so uh
barcelona huh
well it's
not new york but
i like it
new york are these genuinely trying to
say this tech would work
i don't find that let me put my game
face on so i can beat you that's
just in real life
i don't i i could buy that we could be
playing hologram chess
assisted by
probably
glasses or something like that
i could buy that wearing it would put
you know your friend there with their
face just like the current facebook
filters already do
i don't know that i buy this but they're
also not saying this is a concept
obviously they're not trying to tell you
that that would definitely be a thing
maybe you'll go head to head with
players from around the world
yeah this makes sense
some call it skill
keep talking i can't see why glosses
wouldn't be able to do this gaming is
how a lot of people are going to step
into the metaverse for the first time it
already has some of the most fully built
out digital goods the most active
creator and developer communities and
major platforms like epic are working to
build up the universe starting
we're heavily investing we don't have to
make this much eye contact vr and ar
ecosystem you don't have to keep looking
at studios you can look elsewhere and
gaming creators can keep creating now
deb from our studios team is joining me
deb do you want to take us through some
of the exciting games in the pipeline
for quest absolutely
over the years we've had the opportunity
to work with incredible developers like
vertigo games the studio behind fan
favorite arizona sunshine i love arizona
sunshine that game basically got me and
my friends through the first few months
of the pandemic that's this is where i
that's all i watched of this and i was
like
oh my god
hey you're mark zuckerberg don't [ __ ]
lie to me you have
more money
than like me and everybody i know
combined will ever have in our entire
lifetimes like it unfathomable
amounts of money don't lie to me you
didn't need to play a vr game
to get through the pandemic
you were fine
there was no problem for you
but it's also just the like
the fake scripted friendships
this woman
that's awesome what very and video games
and i don't blame her for this nor do i
even blame mark zuckerberg
for this
it they've been directed to do it and
she's not an actress so she can't like
just completely act candidly
enthusiastic about something she's heard
10 times it's not something you can just
do but
it's just a lot it's just there's just
too much happening and it's
it's awesome if you enjoyed that mark i
think you'll be excited that we're
partnering with vertigo on five more
great games from deep silver and others
we'll show you guys about this lineup
very soon nice what else is
this is not her fault i'm so sorry to
this woman i'm so sorry i'm sure that
you are the person who is qualified to
be giving this presentation but that
doesn't make you good on camera all your
direction is terrible and five others
you'll see soon
it's fine it's fine it's fine i'm
interested in the news i do want to know
the news i like five and other video
games
the metaverse is constantly evolving so
one of the most important aspects will
be live service games that launch
updates and new downloadable content
regularly let's just make sure we are
beat saber i love beat saber pistol whip
and more i also like pistols focused on
this a lot right focused on this making
sure games can build out active
communities beat saver has a passionate
community i love beat saber
and bt were just
oh my god
i don't know
why
that got me so bad i just
how do i just get back like a tiny bit i
just want to hear oh i love beat saber
which i say as somebody who [ __ ]
loves beat saber i cannot recommend
beats even more highly i adore
beat saber the live updates they give it
a great i do my workouts in expert plus
and you like i have the calorie tracker
you know it's [ __ ] fantastic but
i love pizza who do i and beat saber
just passed a hundred million dollars in
lifetime revenue on quest alone it's a
great example of a game that keeps
releasing fresh content it is really
good they've actually been working on
evolving the way that you interact with
the tracks and feel the music also the
team has been working on something
really cool check this out
ooh that's new
[Music]
what is it
what is it i can't wait that's it oh i
was actually very interested in that
artist to release new music all the time
got kendricks recently billy island last
month a little more than i should have i
probably been working more on this
metaverse prison i agree well they have
a great lineup of artists for 2022 and
there's one more epic surprise before
the end of the year so stay tuned okay
have you played population one i mean
yeah i love the game so much for those
who haven't population one is a
thrilling battle royale which has
happened that is only possible
since its launch at connect last year it
has become one of the highest earning
games on quest what wasn't he trying to
say something else what just happened
the
thrilling battle royale that is no i'm
so bad at skipping the right time played
population one i mean yeah i love the
game so much for those who have
did she just go shut the [ __ ] up
zuckerbug
shut the [ __ ] up because he was saying
something
what
this has cuts
population one is a thrilling what was
he laughing at that is only possible in
vr since its launch at connect last year
it has become one of the highest earning
games on quest and the biggest
multiplayer fps on the platform you can
on the platform i do want to say
this is maybe for shareholders um
it's very strange
to try to market video games to
your demographic i am your demographic i
am a hardcore vr user i would use it
more frequently
than
99.999 of people right like literally
every day
to try to market
more vr games to me
based on their revenue
doesn't make any sense i don't care how
much money these games are making that
doesn't make me want to buy them you
have to like you know as consumers sell
me on the features of the video game not
on this game is the most successful the
platform is making the most money which
frames this whole thing a little bit
differently um this is the thing that ea
used to do with their conferences that
they've actually uh kind of pivoted in
in recent years
is you can tell when conferences or
presentations are designed for
shareholders or for the stock market
rather than designed for consumers
um and that often leads to a different
presentation style as well if this is
for shareholders and for the stock
market then even that weird what is it
that boarding thing that jump boarding
[ __ ] whatever that was um
surf game thing
even that actually makes sense because
that is for non-gamers um it is not for
the people buying the games it is for
the people that they want to invest in
gaming in the metaverse um
they're kind of like
now it all makes sense this isn't for me
which is why i think it's terrible
have up to 24 people in at once for a
match we're super excited to keep
because even that to a gamer means
nothing 24 people in a match
in a battle royale and a winter
wonderland that means nothing
this is
for people who don't play video games i
think
[Music]
it's not a video game trailer unless you
have dubstep who told facebook that who
told these boomers about that
[Music]
pretty catchy though
[Music]
my guess is actually that this
is a developing developer made
trailer
probably with some insight because i
don't think your devs care about double
xp weekends okay here's something i know
our community has been waiting for lay
it on us all right this is a title from
the warp frog team
sorry i just
i'm having an internal struggle
with
how much i hated watching mark
zuckerberg just say
lay it on us
right
the internal struggle
is that i don't like it makes me feel
bad
i feel shitty making fun of people for
any
social awkwardness
trouble speaking on camera any of that
as someone who
isn't very good on camera and has only
gotten tolerable
through
11 years of practice and it'd be less
than that but
i intentionally made this youtube
channel to get better on camera because
i an awkward as [ __ ] writer
knew
that for me to get where i wanted to in
my career that i couldn't
take the gamble of
sucking at being on camera like i was
like i recognize i want to walk in the
game's retreat full-time
the initial path was games media i was
like i have to be good on camera so i
can also cover that base so i'm as
employable as possible i was terrible
i don't like making fun of people for it
when it's
like almost objectively evil billionaire
who
is knowingly aware of the negative
impact that his business has
on every other human on the planet
you can i feel like maybe i can make fun
of it
i don't i don't know what i'm supposed
to do about it but [ __ ] hell i hated
that i hated that a lot
oh okay a team that set the standard for
vr combat i am excited to find out
that's right blade and sorcery nomad the
filter vr medieval fantasy sandbox that
pairs magic with melee is launching on
quest later this year oh cool
this is uh
quest exclusive i think
it's tough to market vr because no
matter what the graphics look bad but
when you're in it it's incredible i've
been playing resume before vr on the
channel
and it looks like an old video game but
when you're in
vr so [ __ ] cool man
big fan big fan
does this have like proper spell casting
oh there's an assassin there it is that
was assassination
yes dude i am excited about that look
out for the 2022 oculus gaming showcase
it's going to be loaded with news you
won't want to miss but martin i believe
you have some news for us it's every day
you know i have to say
it's really impressive to see this
lineup come together over the last few
years but there is one interesting thing
i'm really looking forward to yeah this
is one of the all-time greats and we've
been working for years to bring it to
quest i'm excited to announce that the
rockstar games ah this is gta grand
theft auto san andreas is in development
for quest two this new version of what i
think is one of the greatest it is one
of the best games i did see this on
twitter so i didn't know about that i'm
stoked about this this is gonna be
[ __ ] awesome it's gonna
why are you talking to each other
all right thanks dad this is going to be
amazing
oh my god
oh
i don't feel good about it and i'm sorry
everybody i i don't
no one [ __ ] cares with me about this
[ __ ] but i don't like the idea
that i'm laughing at how uncomfortable
somebody makes me and that anybody else
who's socially awkward who could be
watching this would feel the same way
because i too
am socially awkward
it's hard to watch
i i feel like you should get other
people to present
i think you should think about it i
think you should think about it um not a
ton of gaming information there i am
excited to see what a company with this
much money continues to do
with that
platform as someone who again is always
just interested in advancements in video
game technology in general but
um
also especially does really like vr i
like ar but nowhere near as much i think
vr is just the coolest
uh i still have fears
um if the intent is just for the
algorithm to feed me video games and and
microtransactions
that's fine i i won't spend my money on
microtransactions i will continue to buy
oculus games i
i really like them um
however i've always had this ongoing
concern
where facebook is concerned because of
the money or the amount of money that
they generate from
ads
that i'm not going to get video game ads
i'm going to get
say i have to watch
an ad for 30 seconds before i get to a
cut scene
or something along those lines
um
i guess i am spending money on
microtransactions in beat saber i do buy
the new packs frequently so i am i am
doing that um they've got me there but
like
other than that that game
doesn't
interrupt your play you can just play an
hour whatever you want straight beat
saber it's super fun and i've always had
this fear of it leading down a path
where once the audience install gets
bigger they lure in people like me by
giving you really solid gaming
experiences in a new platform and just
so so immersive and so cool
that once i've spoken enthusiastically
to enough of you about it that it gets
more popular
and they've drawn enough people in
then we start having ads in the middle
of video games and i really don't want
that that yeah you have to watch an ad
for 30 seconds
um
in order to get to a cut scene
or something along those lines
and um
i worry that that being introduced on
this platform and us getting used to it
will then lead to its introduction
in video games across the board and um
i don't know it feels like a like a
a wild guess but i am genuinely
concerned about it that there is a
future where in 15 years
you're playing
whatever game that you would already
play and there is not only egregious
product placement um like we already
have little bits of
but there are requirements like youtube
for if you want to play an hour of this
game you need to watch three ads to get
through it and as someone who's working
um on a single player video game
god
mortifying and obviously somebody's
played them my whole life so it
definitely concerns me um
for now i'm still really excited about
the tech and i think oculus rules
just maybe get anyone else anyone else
to do that anyway
my name is alana thank you for watching
at home i will see you guys next time